you know the good uh good day team has
been in your neighborhood
exploring different parts of our diverse
valuable today
sheri swiss will be on the east side in
sunrise manor she'll join us live in the
next half hour for now
how about a look at the real estate
market in that part of town so sherry
found a young couple are trying to
decide
whether to cash in and move up or hold
on to their investment for a while
realtor alex vasquez has been on the go
since the pandemic shutdown last year
the las vegas housing market is red hot
and many homeowners like andrew and jen
hurtado
are wondering if it's time to cash in on
the value of their home
it has actually doubled we're constantly
getting uh
bombarded by it in the mail calls people
trying to buy our house and
that kind of got the idea going should
we sell
or just buy a second property you guys
already know the areas where we want to
be
what budget you're comfortable with so
they called vasquez with coldwell banker
to explore their options
the hurtados are young married
professionals who moved to sunrise manor
five years ago
looking for an affordable first home in
a community they identify with
the cultural connection i think is the
biggest selling point for us
being within walking distance of
of some of our favorite foods and snacks
like our local vendors
that's kind of the vibe we're looking
for and we aim to stay around it
that's what we like that's what we grew
up with and that's kind of what brings
us to the east side of las vegas
vasquez heads up the new home experts
office in henderson
with clients all over the valley he
knows the established east side
offers what many other areas can't so
you could get a lot more
backyard more front yard more green
there's no hoas
to tell you exactly how to how to keep
up your home but
new home builders are creating more
choices for buyers in this area
lennar homes is one of three builders
making progress
on brand new developments which sound
pricey for sunrise manor it's still very
affordable
particularly with the low interest rates
but you're looking at a brand new home
in the east side for about three hundred
and fifty thousand as opposed to a
summerlin
where you're looking in the five hundred
thousand vasquez says that's certainly
one option for the hurtados
but the couple says they'd also like to
move up the hill to a larger home with a
bigger yard
for their rambunctious family whatever
they choose they know the east side
is home jerry tells us that vasquez says
land is at a premium in the east valley
there's going to be three new
developments the royal links golf course
has been sold to a developer
who's talking about putting in upwards
of 1200 new homes there
and coming up at 4 30 sherry will join
us live got a great story about a local
woman who is giving her talents back to
the community
in sunrise manor